tripoli dans la brume des gaz
lacrymogènes forces de l'ordre et
manifestants se sont affrontés pendant
plusieurs heures ce lundi des centaines
de personnes ont défilé dans les rues et
lancé des pierres sur le siège des
autorités locales dans la deuxième ville
du pays selon la croix rouge libanaise
une trentaine de personnes ont été
blessées les manifestants protestent
contre le prolongement du confinement
dans le pays et la fermeture de tous les
commerces
jusqu'au 8 février une décision prise
par les autorités pour soulager les
hôpitaux saturés mais qui aggrave encore
la crise économique au pays du cèdre
nous allons ouvrir nous allons mourir
depuis quatorze quinze jours nous sommes
enfermés à la maison nous n'avons plus
d'argent ce n'est pas dans nos habitudes
vous voyez tout ce qui se passe tout
cela est à cause des dirigeants tout
état cause de vous nabih berry et michel
aoun cacher derrière vos posts vous
aimez vos posts et vous vous tenez avec
l'armée en face de nous jusqu'à ce que
vous nous plus y est à bout et nous ne
pouvons pas nous battre avec l'armée
c'est impossible l'armée à notre armée
tout est de votre faute c'est tout ce
que je veux dire les gens ont faim les
gens n'ont pas de pain chez eux pas de
gaz pas d'essence nous n'avons plus rien
les gens sont au plus bas
l'état libanais ne se soucie pas de ses
habitants et les néglige ils sont dans
leur palais pour eux ça ne fait aucune
différence mais nous à tripoli avant fin
face à la situation sanitaire et
économique que traverse le pays la
banque mondiale a annoncé le financement
de la distribution de vaccins d'ici le
mois prochain une première pour
l'institution
une enveloppe de 34 millions de dollars
sera débloqué pour fournir des vaccins à
environ deux millions de personnes